the one that I've been working on the
longest is in Puerto Rico and well we're
interested in trying to understand there
is how the process of agricultural
abandonment s countries go through seven
on the development oftentimes would you
see the perineum which go to is
abandoned and then you tropical areas
particularly wet tropical areas you know
for is just groups and so we're trying
to understand where the dynamics of that
by for a girl with as far as a girl why
and ways important substance abandoning
factors versus you know the presence of
other forests that can act as seed
sources and so forth and so that's kind
of like the big picture issues but I'm
more interested in the big question from
the point of view of kind of global
issues is whether this is not a
phenomenon that is limited to Puerto
Rico this is happening all over the
world so to what the Greek and
bridging and so you know we look at
things like can they provide the kind of
biodiversity can they provide you know
so people would tell topical for is you
know they provide carbon they clean
water flow they do all these things
right and so we look at kind of larger
scale and trying to understand what is
that true or not I bought a scale
through these processes operates I'm
very interested you know if you sort of
look at the what unites my research
interests I'm very interested in how
processes change put a different scale
filter right because often times
decisions have to be made different
units at the National Laboratories at
the municipality level so to what degree
can we provide information that is
useful this particular because the
players are different the stoker new
stakeholders are different so that's a
big thing